por primera vez desde el inicio de la
pandemia los jóvenes brasileños son los
más afectados por el cob y 19 desde
marzo más del 52% de las camas de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos están
ocupadas por pacientes de 40 años o
menos según el informe de la asociación
brasileña de medicina intensiva un
significativo aumento en comparación con
la ocupación de este rango de edad entre
diciembre y febrero del 16 5% las
audiencias han tenido esta enfermedad no
tiene edad es muy triste
desgraciadamente de un día para otro te
puede llevar muy muy triste el reporte
se basa en datos del 25 por ciento de
las uci de brazil el epicentro mundial
de la pandemia según los expertos esta
tendencia de la pandemia sugiere que la
variante brasileña del virus es más
agresiva con la población joven las que
la vacunación de los adultos mayores ha
ayudado a contener los casos graves
entre los ancianos
en la primera ola vimos principalmente a
personas mayores pero esto no es lo que
estamos viendo ahora es una enfermedad
que se ha mostrado más agresiva sobre
todo en los más jóvenes ya que estos
jóvenes aplazan la visita al hospital
la nación suramericana está sumida en
una nueva crisis de la enfermedad con
más de 4 mil decesos diarios la semana
pasada un rebrote que se refleja en su
desbordado sistema de salud una de cada
cuatro ciudades brasileñas tiene lista
de espera de pacientes en estado grave
que aguardan por una cama de las ucis
nosotros hemos sido testigos de un gran
número de pacientes que han fallecido
debido a la falta de camas de la uci en
el estado de sao paulo porque la gestión
de la pandemia brasil ha estado marcada
por el negacionismo del gobierno de jair
bolsonaro el incremento de jóvenes
preocupa a las autoridades sanitarias en
un país donde la mayor parte de su
población es menor de 40 años